they closed down schools in New York so
illegals could go in there and sleep
while the kids are staying at home I
want to Yo New Yorkers where are you at
where is the outcry nobody gives a
and then they're released and they're
doing this this is to you America this
is that's their attitude because Joe
Biden and this Administration Pat is
doing this on purpose those are votes
and just to throw this in there uh what
is this bill called oh yeah Democrats
voted against the bill yesterday to uh
not to deport illegals that get arrested
for drunk driving these people are
Untouchable they have more rights than
you do than we do in here and my
question is this when is enough going to
be enough when is when are Americans
going to say like they're doing in Texas
the hell with this bro there's no more
like you said all the politicians and
the hell with that and New Yorkers
where you at yeah where where's the New
Yorkers stepping up for New York